hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round two of this
year's Global chess League uh it is
Alexander grishuk versus sorry about no
videos for the past few days I had a
sort of uh uh well sort of a vacation
with the family and I just got back and
I decided to check up on what's what in
the Chess World and immediately I was
greeted with this game so I'm very happy
to present it to you uh a very very cool
end game and uh very very resourceful uh
find by one of the players so like I
said the global chess League it is a six
team double round robin tournament
taking place from June 22nd to July 1st
uh in Dubai and also the players receive
15 minutes for the entire game plus also
10 seconds increment uh after a movie's
played so it's a rapid time format let's
check it out uh Alexander grishuk has
the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he goes for the retina we
have Ponte D5 G3
uh the king's Indian attack and Knight
to F6 with Bishop to G2 E6 and now
castles with Pawn to C5 so nothing new
here uh dugoslav variation we have D3
Knight to C6 and now Pawn to E4 this is
a a very standard Pawn sacrifice uh but
white will get a lot for it so D
captures an E4 we have D capitals now we
have a queen trade Queen characters and
D1 real characters and now Knight
captures on e4 and now Knight to A3 and
what's interesting is that okay uh White
is up upon uh sorry black is up upon
that black will have uh problems
developing the light Square bishop and
also another back probably I have no
idea if he does but he probably knows
that grishop already played this in the
video World a rapid championship and
that he won a very nice game against
Daniel Friedman but there is a
difference after Bishop t7 uh in that
game uh four years ago grishop played
Bishop to F4 and controlling this
diagonal and of course um if black
allows it you want to get your knight
all the way to C7 but most likely the
Knight is coming to C4 but here he plays
Bishop to E3 and it is now already as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game so here we have Castles by another
back Knight the D2 offering a trade of
knights and okay captures captures and
here uh Ponte E5 this is the uh the
quick way to develop it because it comes
with a uh with a pawn sacrifice but you
really have no ways of developing your
your light score Bishop so here we have
Knight to C4 uh putting pressure on D5
Pawn
uh but this also means that white will
have the part with his light Square
Bishop but uh capture the Knight here
which will also double black spawns into
which also means that you will be able
to capture an E5 so well you could play
something like F6 then you allow Bishop
to D5 and you just give white more
control over the entire board so Bishop
to E6 uh and as we've promised Bishop
captures on C6 now you could throw in a
nice Bishop captures on C4 but then
Bishop captures and B7 so B captors and
C6 we have Knight captures and E5 going
after the C6 pawn and Rook F the C8
defending it with Pawn to B3 and now
Bishop to F6 not allowing the Knight to
move so Pawn to F4 you have to defend it
and now uh one move you don't want to
see is white playing C4 so that's why
another big first place Bishop captures
on E5 F captures and only Now Pawn to C4
and now of course he wants to trade his
Double C Pawn uh for uh White's um uh a
perfect Pawn structure and he wants to
uh push A5 A4 and put even more pressure
on that B3 Pawn so Bishop to C5 and now
Pawn to H5 creating some breathing room
for the black king Rook to D4 and now
Rook seat sorry about that uh and now
um
uh sorry about that um
uh and now uh Rooks Rook C to B8 after
this uh Rook the D4 movies played Rook B
to C8 Rook C to B8 Rook 8 to D1 and now
Pawn to A5 uh what just happened you've
seen nothing don't pause the video or
anything to check out the position so
Ponte A5 of course the idea is Pawn to
A4 and now King death two uh Sasha
starts bringing the king into the game
King H7 another week does the same Rook
one to D2 and now Ponte A4 now you are
ready to start capturing on B3 uh and of
course uh uh Sasha just plays B captures
on C4 and there are two moves actually
to consider here one is B captures and C
for the movie The degrees you played the
other one is spawned to B4 and it's hard
to find anything wrong with this move
but okay uh B counters and C four and up
onto A3 you will give a black a a bit
more activity uh we have Rook uh four
back to D3 and now Rook to B2 going
after the A2 Pawn Rook captures an A3
Rook captures with Bishop captures and
finally Rook captures on A2
Bishop back D7 and Bishop characters in
C4 and now okay the material is equal
Bishops are of opposite color obviously
this is a draw is what you would think
but one of the players is a very very
low on time and I don't have to tell you
uh which of the players is it so Bishop
to G5 we have King to G6 and now Pawn to
H4 defending the bishop and now also the
the black king can't really uh well he
can advance but it could be a little bit
dangerous but that's exactly what
another big does he plays King to F5
Bishop to F4 defense the E5 pawn and now
Rook the A3 cuts off the white king from
entering the game Rook to D6 now attacks
the a C6 pawn and Rook the A6 just
defends The Pawn King E3 and Bishop to
D5 down now The Rook can once again move
we have King taditu and now Rook the A4
uh we have wrote back to the eighth King
to G4 uh Rook to Jade attacking the pawn
and pawn to G6 with Rook to d8 and now
Rook the A3 uh Rook to D6 and now Rook
back to A4 you could um uh also consider
maybe a move like Rook characters on G3
uh but it would be it would be
ill-advised for example Rook captures
and G3 Bishop characters King characters
uh there's no real way to make progress
with your pawns like you could play okay
maybe play G5 characters and then create
a past H Pawn and you do have the H1
Square covered uh but it sort of feels a
bit over ambitious it is similar to what
actually happened in the game but not
not quite the same Rook the A4 was
played King to D3 King F3 and now King
to D2
uh Rook day two now you have to be
careful you don't want to allow Bishop
to B3 so King the C3 and now Rook the A4
uh point is if you play Bishop T for now
you will win the pawn but um uh let the
king be three you force The Rook to
capture and after Rook captures now you
even play Pawn to E6 and after F
captures Rook captures how do you uh
play this let's say Bishop to F5 uh okay
you chase away The Rook Rook the E5 and
now if uh uh it's hard to find the move
because uh you are threatening Rook
captures on F5 then The Rook will hang
uh the king will be able to capture the
rook and also this Rook cannot remain on
the C file which means that you will not
be able to advance the
uh the past three Pawn as the bishop
covers C1 the king covers C2 C3 and C4
and The Rook over C5 uh that's pretty
much it it's uh it's just a draw uh I
mean it often is like that when it's a
bishops of opposite color so Rook to A4
and now King the D2 with King D4 Rook to
d8 and now Bishop to E6 Rook to D3 C5
the pawn is now being Advanced um
uh to C4 we have rooked the C3 and pawn
to C4 so uh limiting the movement of
that white rook and white king Rook date
Richard King to F5 and now King to C3 we
have Rook to A1 King the D2 and King to
G4 we have Rook to E4 King the H3 even
Rook D3 and now Rook to G1 C3 uh and
Bishop to D5 now okay you are nicely
controlling this diagonal but what is
there to play for well Rook the E1 uh
grishuk offers a trade of Rooks and uh
uh you you'd probably think that okay
now it's definitely a draw uh but
another bag does not trade another place
Rook captures on G3 he sacrifices The
Rook or rather the exchange uh for for
uh grabbing an extra pawn and now it
will be somewhat difficult to defend
defend especially since gurishuk has
only a few seconds on the clock okay you
do have increment uh but um you know 10
seconds increment although it can mean a
lot uh in a difficult position and this
is a difficult end game might not be
enough King characters and G3 and now
King to E3 here uh there is a sort of a
forced line but impossible to find with
few seconds on the clock look at this E6
you sacrifice another pawn and after
Bishop capture 76 now white is down two
points about okay upper rook and now we
play Rook to E4 and this is the problem
now the H4 Pawn is defended and you
don't have ways of pushing forward for
example Bishop to D5 uh let's say we
attack The Rook Rook to D4 and now okay
you can play Bishop back to E6 and now
after King day three even upon the F5
but that's as far as you get because D4
and therefore are dark squares and you
will simply play Rook D4 Rook F4 Rook D4
rookie for Rook D4 and black will not be
able to make progress you only have a
light Square Bishop so you cannot affect
the dark squares and you cannot push any
of the pawns uh I mean uh it's sad
you're up two pawns but nothing to be
done however in the game King the E3 was
played and now there's a bit more to be
done here King captures on H4 and still
it's a draw if you play Rook to G1 your
Rook G1 uh completely cuts off the the
black king from entry in the game
however King the F2 was played and now
uh well I don't have to tell you uh uh
what another big played um as I've just
told you that you have to cut the black
king off from entering the G file uh
King to G4 of course we have King to G1
King to F4 we have King to H2 and now
Pawn to G5 and now the pawns are
Marching forward and the white Rook will
be helpless against them with King to H3
uh Bishop T6 with check forcing the king
back King to H2 and now Pawn to H4 uh
Andy was in this position on move 59 and
that Alexander grishuk resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here and it was a pretty pretty bold
decision by nederbeck to sacrifice The
Exchange like that because uh okay it's
a team event six players versus six
players and even if he got a draw uh it
would be enough for his team to win but
he's still you know sacrificed material
he went for the win uh Peter swiller
even joked on the stream a little bit he
said that if he did this as a kid you
know with his captain uh he would be
well maybe not kicked off the team but
uh maybe maybe he would not be allowed
to play uh a few games after that uh but
yeah here are the standings of what
happened in the other uh games of uh of
this matchup there you have it uh uh MBL
uh drew his game against the animation
lost another back and also in this
tournament if you win with the white
pieces you only get three points if you
win with black pieces you get four
points so it's uh again a bit of a
different way of um of scoring uh with
it versus teamwork after really a crazy
crazy game and the draw uh hampi versus
tanjongin uh also uh one with the black
uh hurricane uh defeated uh Nino with uh
with white and cindaro lost around also
he got very nicely Four Points with
white and that means the ball and Alaska
Knights have defeated the uh Mumba the
upgrad Mumba Masters by a score of 14-5
which is uh well which is quite a lot uh
and if you're wondering how one would
play out of this game if it didn't end
where it did well it's it's been much
what you think it is you just Advance
the pawns the king G2 G4 King H2 G3 with
checking G1
now of course you cannot go up the board
and now Bishop to D5 and you can even
make uh you know Silly moves like a
fruit D1 you can even capture back
defend the bishop if you give a check
now you block with the bishop uh if you
try some checks via the a file you will
simply play H3 now h2a1 wins if Rook A5
checking F4 if row goes here H2 check
King F1 you can win with H1 check but
you don't have to you can even threaten
a nice Checkmate here if rockage for
checking E3 and now G2 check and that's
uh all there is if King T1 you can even
play G2 right away and now you are
checkmating white uh whatever you play
okay you could prolong with rookie for
check but we are not going to discuss
such moves so after H4 after 59 moves
grishock resigned another back wins a
very nice game and uh yes I am back from
vacation so if you guys have any games
that you would like covered uh that I
haven't shown of course I as I was on
vacation uh do send them to me via via
email via Twitter via pretty much
anything I will check it out and will
gladly show them uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Brian Baker uh bullet just
thriller.com Sammy okay and then
McCormick and Eugene uh Eugene James
Eugene Cashman for your contribution to
my channel uh thank you a lot I really
appreciate it uh sorry about that
uh forgot to enter the the amount Mr Mr
James
uh there you have it
[Music]
uh sorry about that
there we go
uh and yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens uh
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day